Hello everybody. I'm so excited to be
here with you today. A couple of things.
One to make sure we have a dialogue
because if all I do is talk to you about
maybe a few nightmares,
maybe a few scary things,
tell you a few White House stories
and that's all that happened,
then I only did half my job.
So I want to make sure that you
feel like you can ask me questions.
And for those of you that
are live streaming in your
questions are going to be
moderated by Heather.
And we were talking about making sure
everybody's questions get answered.
We're going to find a way to do that
even if we run out of our time together.
And then for those of
you that are in the room,
your incentive plan is to ask a question
and the first one to ask a question,
you get a signed copy of my book,
which my mother says is a must read.
And uh, and then if you don't
ask questions and you're
too shy to ask questions,
then I ask random people random questions.
So that's your incentive plan
for asking me a question.
I really want to make
sure we have a dialogue.
I'm really honored to
be here with all of you.
For those of you who are live streaming
in as a view who were here in person. Uh,
Google is one of the power brokers of
the world and I'm a big fan of Google.
I've also held Google, uh, accountable.
I'm in talking about privacy and security,
but I'm a big fan. As a matter of fact,
I power our company's infrastructure.
A big part of it is on the Google cloud.
So big fan of Google and I want to
push you out of your comfort zone.
So when I talked to the
people putting on this event,
one of the things they said is try out
some new concepts and new ideas and I'm
going to do that today.
Uh,
disagreement is always welcome so
you don't have to agree with me. I'm,
the only way I'm going to learn is for
people to share alternative points of
view and idea. So your questions
can be anything, any topic,
and feel free to push back on anything
that you hear me talk about today.
A couple of quick pictures
from the family scrapbook.
So you'll see in the family photo,
I've got my two sons, Kiran and Aiden.
I'm actually seven months pregnant
with my little girl made there and the
gentleman next to me
with his arm around me,
that's President Bush and the dude next
to him. That's actually my husband. Um,
then you have another picture of, uh, the
White House press briefing room, podium.
And you can probably tell I'm actually
holding up my son and decking behind him.
And I love that picture because, you know,
it's one of those things where my, um,
I commuted every week for two and a half
years. I don't know if you know this,
but the shelf life of a political
appointee CIO is roughly 12 to 14 months.
I did it for two and a half years.
So that either says I'm
crazy or determined and
stubborn or maybe a little bit
of all of the above. Uh, but sometimes
instead of me commuting home,
my family would actually come to see me
and the senior staff really encouraged
for them to come and experience the
White House as I experienced it.
And so on this particular day,
actually, kids were like, mom,
you have the coolest job in the world.
And they were right.
And I still have the coolest job in
the world. It's just a different job.
But this particular day they saw the
president land on the South Lawn and Hmx
one the helicopter. Then they saw the
president's dogs, Bernie and Ms. Beasley.
And Barney was outfitted with a camera.
So you could see the White House
from Barneys point of view,
I'm Barney can then people were handing
them presidential mnms everywhere they
went. And they're like,
this job is amazing.
You helped the president
with this computer. You get
to watch helicopters land,
play with dogs and eat m and m's kind of
sounds like Google, doesn't it? Right.
And so, uh, we went into
the press briefing room,
which is one of the few places where
I could actually talk about my job.
And we were doing this major modernization
effort in the press briefing room.
And behind that podium,
which is the president had been there,
they'd actually be a presidential seal
on the podium and its nickname is called
the blue goose.
But behind that is almost its own
little city of cables and wires and uh,
programs running things from the blue
goose. My kids are bored at this point.
So my oldest turns to me, those were
getting ready to leave. And he says, Mama,
I really want to tell the news.
And so as I ducked down so my husband
could take that picture of him telling the
news,
it dawned on me,
wouldn't it be great if we let four year
olds give the press briefings in the
White House? I mean, think about
the honesty we would get. Right. Um,
and then down at the bottom there's a
picture of me in front of one of the jets
in the Air Force One fleet.
And this is where the job that you have
and the job that I had are actually not
too different. So if you think
about the White House for starters,
the 3000 staff that worked for the
executive office of the president,
they're barely ever at the White House.
We don't all fit in the White House.
It was built for kinder, gentler,
smaller time in our US government.
They're mobile,
they're global,
they deserve and in some cases demand
the latest and greatest technology.
How do you give them the latest and
greatest technology to enable them to do
their jobs without,
for me anyways,
putting a homing beacon and
the president's pocket was
not an ideal thing to do
for you. It might be a little
different what you're worried about,
but you're still worried
about the security and the
privacy in addition to the
functionality. And so if you think about
it, our jobs are not too dissimilar,
right?
And the challenges we face every day.
And we're at this really
exciting time in computing.
And Heather and I were talking about
just how amazing it is and we don't even
know what quantum computing is
going to bring for all of us.
And it's exciting and scary at the same
time. And we now have a point where,
you know,
devices are collecting and interacting
with each other on our behalf without
human intervention.
It is an amazing time of innovation and
the technology that's being deployed is
so cool.
So I don't know about you.
When you think about commercial
travel and you think about elegant,
classy service, do you think flying on
airlines these days? Maybe, maybe not.
Probably not.
I mean I think Air Force One,
but I don't fly on that as much anymore.
And so I think you kind of as
second best is virgin airlines.
I think they do a pretty good job whether
you're in first class are in coach.
And so how do they do that? And I looked
into what virgin airlines was doing.
The first thing they did was they've
outfitted every plane with Internet of
things, devices from nose to tail
wing to wing, inside and outside. Now,
that's not to say while they're flying,
they're all communicating
with the Internet.
But the devices are collecting information
and that information is used to think
about safer flying or
their mechanical issues,
more economical flying.
So how do I give you elegant,
classy service while having
it be economical at the
same time and being on time.
So on time records, how much data
are they collecting? One plane,
one flight is a half a terabyte of data.
Now I know this group knows what
a half a terabyte of data is,
but if your mom and dad
asks you what it is,
it's the equivalent of binge watching
250 hours of your favorite shows.
One plane, one flight, Virgin Airlines.
That is a massive amount of data,
but it's really cool how it's being used.
Now,
in some cases where we're headed
with technology can even save lives.
So in the UK they actually
have internet of things,
lamps and these lamps actually
detect glass breaking,
yelling, banging, loud noises,
and the lamps actually
glow brighter and brighter.
In some cases a camera will turn on and
they could deploy physical security if
they need to. These are really cool
and interesting uses of technology.
And then of course Google, not to leave
out Google, we have Google helmet,
my house,
that was actually the employee gift last
year for Christmas for everybody in our
company. Now everything has to be gold.
That's given us the employee gift.
So we had to search for the gold rappers,
which came out later,
but long story about that.
But if you think about sort of the
integration of some of this technology,
it's almost to the point where we
don't even realize it's there anymore.
And the opportunity is huge. When you
look at the economic value for the world,
we're looking at possibly $11 trillion
positive impact and we've now outnumber
humans with the number of
Iot devices around the world.
So where do we go from here?
Well,
one of the first things I want you to
be thinking about since it's internet
safety awareness month, right? So
national cybersecurity awareness month,
it's also international cyber
security awareness month.
And this is the 13th year that we're
doing this. Do you guys feel safer?
I don't know about you.
I don't.
I'm so 13 years in lucky 13 first thing
I want you to think about changing is
how many of you have heard
the conventional wisdom that
the human is the weakest
link in security? Right? So,
uh, we all say it. We all say,
I want to change the dialogue.
So I want to push back on everybody
here and ask you to question why do we
still,
after over a decade,
we're lie on the human and
say they're the weakest link.
Maybe just maybe I'll
push this idea out to you.
The maybe given the hockey
sticks we have in Cybercrime,
the maybe given the
geopolitics of the world,
and I don't know about you
if you're a history buff,
it's never felt more tense than it has
for me based on what I've read of ancient
history and modern history.
It feels pretty tense to me.
Maybe it's because I'm living in it.
Maybe it's because we're all, you know,
living in it.
It feels more intense to us that maybe
world war one or World War II or the Cold
War,
right?
Okay.
But maybe we should be thinking about,
no, the weakest link is actually us.
I started off as a developer.
Maybe there is a moral imperative
that when we talk about feature and
functionality,
the first thing we should be talking
about is let's not depend on the weakest
link,
the human.
So I'm going to push that out as something
I want each of you to consider is we
need to change that dialogue because
if we keep relying on a human,
we're going to keep failing
and we can't afford to fail.
Cyber criminals have never been,
uh, kind of more organized,
more talented, um, and in
some cases more scalable.
So we're seeing the attacks
cost a lot of money,
so you don't even have
to be technical anymore.
You can buy your way
into attacking companies.
And so it all starts with designs.
I really want to push hard on this concept
of how do we think differently about
design? And maybe some of it starts
with thinking about ethical hacking.
So before you even build that piece of
functionality and maybe you bring the
ethical hacker in, not for them to
throw a wet blanket on your fire,
on the great idea that you're trying to
innovate, but to turn to them and say,
so how would you break this before I
even build it? How would you break it?
How would you take advantage
of the human that's using it?
How do we not be relying upon the
human that's the weakest link?
And for me,
I have to tell you what am I
tipping points when I first
got to the White House,
you know,
I used to work in the financial services
industry and so every time bad things
would happen, the financial services
industry, I think to myself,
if I could just get to every user and
if I could just talk to you for a little
bit and train you a little bit better and
write the policies a little bit better,
like life would be so much better. And
that's all it is. It's communications,
it's training.
We just got to do this better.
And when I got to the White House
and I realized, okay, wait a minute,
cause there's 3000 people here,
they're global, they're mobile,
just like our banking customers were.
So I didn't think that was two different.
But the threats that we're targeting,
the White House were ever changing.
And I thought if I'm going to try and
brief everybody every day on what I'm
learning is different and I'm going to
hold them accountable for understanding
how to protect themselves,
I'm going to fail.
And that's when I realized I wasn't
always designing for the human.
And I'll talk to you in a little bit
about how to think about designing for the
human. And one of my Aha
moments at the White House.
But I've had a second Aha moment lately
and this really happened to me in the
last year.
And it really came to the forefront
with the discussion around the election
cycle,
not just in the u s but over in
Europe and the potential for Russia,
possibly other countries to use propaganda
to change people's minds and opinions
and potentially have them change
how they vote. And that domain is,
we were so focused on,
okay,
the humans weakest link and we need
to protect the servers and we need to
protect the data and we need to protect
the devices that we forgot to protect
crowdsourcing and crowd thinking.
And so when that effort to be thinking
about how do we reach people and how do
we stay interconnected and how do we
get information in a way that we want to
receive it, that's the most beneficial
to us in that moment that we receive it.
Right?
So if you order something on Amazon,
it tells you what other people
who ordered that ordered.
And a lot of times you think that's
pretty cool, I'd probably need that too.
And that's helpful. But at the same
time, is that technology matured.
It also created unintended echo chambers,
which I'll talk about in a moment,
but I want you to be thinking about the
domain of security has now added a new
domain. So it's not just
data, it's not just devices,
it's not just the humans,
but it's actually the social media content
as well that needs to be protected.
And if you read a security briefing,
I don't know how many of you have the
soul crushing pleasure of reading security
reports on a regular basis,
but they all pretty much sound like this.
The Sky is falling.
Data's at risk attacks or worsening,
and the silly user, it's their problem.
They pretty much all sound that way.
Now I'm going to show you a couple of
clips from hunted to show you why it's
really not something that
the user can always prevent.
And so what are you going
to see in this first clip?
In a couple of caveats on hunted,
when you see the command center,
none of us are actors and
actresses were just working cases.
We're trying to forget. The cameras
are there, it's not scripted.
And so everything you
see that we're doing,
if we're trying to hack into
an account or get information,
it's all in real time.
So in this first one I'll show you the
video and then I'll explain to you what,
what's going on.
Concrete Intel on David and Emily's
whereabouts did mark NSA analyst,
Landon Stewart attempts to break
into David's online accounts.
And when does your [inaudible] dot
com I'm going to get into Gmail.
Which message? Lumberjack downtown
one. A fugitive goes on the run.
And Mike Pearse thing,
because I'm a cyber guy,
I want to know how to leverage
technology against them.
One of the security questions for a
reset is his favorite sports team.
So what is his favorite sports team?
Charles, let me see here. All right,
Alana is Instagram, which, which sport?
The Lakers.
He's seeing in the Atlanta Braves,
but that's pumping his favorite
Miami heat as photos up. Tracy.
He's from Miami, right? Miami
Heat. That would be my bet.
My only concern is do store
best not to lock him out.
That's why I won't have it verified by
more than one source. Oh, of course.
You guys are saying he too. Yeah, he's
at the game three weeks ago. Let me see.
Mark. Screw skirt. Screw it. Let's try it.
Got It. It's the heat. Oh, you
rock. We'll ask a question.
When did you create this
Google account? Okay, let's,
let's try and be smart about it.
Um,
let me Google the account and see about
when it appears. Just gimme a second.
Let me see here.
Here's the oldest one.
I see it's January of 2014.
It might be the best shot your gun.
This is a crude way of doing, but it's
the best one. I could be that one.
That's no guarantee.
Oh my God, it worked.
We've got all his contacts.
Oh, we have everybody
do it. That's awesome.
Okay, so a couple of things about what
you just saw there. And first of all,
whenever we heard that the
fugitives had a Google account,
we would just grown because we were like,
oh,
based on Google Security
and privacy settings,
they're the hardest ones to get into. And
so we would actually have to file, um,
I'd have to send a
written thing to a judge.
I never got to meet with who always
said no. Pretty much everything.
So I'd always have to
justify what our techniques,
we're in the cyber and Intel group and
I finally got a yes, David winded. Sure.
Used to be a criminal.
He's now a defense attorney.
He was a formidable opponent as a
fugitive on the run. Just really,
really smart at what he was doing.
And we had actually recovered his
laptop from the scene at which he fled,
but he had logged out of his account,
didn't have two factor authentication on.
And so we finally got the okay from the
judge to hack into the account and we
knew if we messed up those questions
too many times when we knew we would be
locked out and the judge said we'd be
on our own and those clues were critical
to us. I won't give you a spoiler alert,
but they were critical to the case. Oh,
and by the way, land and who also
works for my company, I joked with him,
he's the only one that throughout the
show would get some titles and it's
because he's from Pittsburgh. So I'm like,
I guess because you speak Pittsburgh,
could they have to do subtitles for
you and not everybody else? All right,
so we'll go to the next video
team. I'm going to assign this to Steve,
former naval intelligence officer.
Steve Masterson begins to build a profile
on Troy and Shelly crosscheck public
records. Who are they? What do
they do? We've been married,
their high school sweethearts.
Did they seem to be best friends?
I don't think they're
going to separate it.
I'll tell you obviously can stand hours
together. Yup. Kids, no kids. Okay.
So in this particular one,
again just from a,
and realize the bad guys do this too
to your customers. Right? So they,
we were trying to figure
out Troy and Shelly,
I had the suspicion they
were hiding out in the swamp.
They actually had an airsoft business.
They had done a lot of camping as part
of their air soft business and the
airsoft community was not talking to
us. They literally, and that that's,
that's their friends and family
was the Airsoft community.
So we were trying to figure out from a
social media profile like do they have
kids? Like would the
kids be a clue? No kids.
But we did find out they had a
pet who meant a lot to Shelly.
And so we had a lot of rules of things
we couldn't do to lower people. And,
but one of the things I wanted to do
was just have the vet call Shelley's mom
just to check in and to see when Shelley
was going to check in on the pat.
Not to say the pet was sick cause I'm
a pet lover myself or anything. Um,
and at that point I was told,
I know it's not written the rules but
you're really cold person and we're ready
to get into the rules that you
can't talk about pets. So anyways,
pets were taken off the table.
Uh,
but you could see how just
using a social media profile,
we were trying to get a feel
for where they would be.
They had a hundred thousand square
miles they were allowed to hide in.
And just by studying them on Airsoft,
I knew they weren't going to,
they were airsoft.
I'm enthusiastic.
I'm looking at their air soft websites
that they would participate in as well as
the two of them got along so well.
Most likely they weren't going to argue
they were going to be a good support
network for each other.
All right. One more video
I can command center.
The cyber teams.
Facebook wanted poster is widening the
circle of associates for fugitives.
Troy and Shelly guys don't pay attention
to this post. It is not Shelly postings.
Snitches get stitches,
snitches get stitches.
So month to figure out who J D is.
I love the results of what's happening
on this Facebook wanted poster.
We're getting new names and context
we didn't have access to before.
It's incredibly helpful.
So in this particular one,
again,
the community was not talking to us and
so we got permission from the judge to
actually flip their social media profile
to a wanted poster and I knew that they
weren't going to, nobody was going
to turn them in. I knew that,
but what I knew was this,
whoever seemed to defend them the most
was probably somebody I wanted to put
under surveillance. And that
actually ended up helping
us out a lot. In that case,
if somebody who spoke up a lot and told
people not to talk to us and not to help,
we actually went to her house.
Um,
and we are actually ended up in 24 hours
apprehending them with the tips and
nobody outdid them. But it was just
the way people behaved on social media.
It gave us a clue that they might be their
lifeline. And so what does that mean?
So we still have,
not only do we have sort of this new
brave world of social engineering where
it's never been easier
to do for the bad guys,
but we've got these old school breaches
that are coming up in the headlines,
whether it's one or cry pet ya
not pet the SCC Edgar database,
Equifax. And I'm not picking on these
companies. I mean the way I look at it,
is there a victim of a cyber crime?
You may like what they did before and
after and how they handled the breach.
You may agree or disagree,
but they are victims of a crime.
But we've got these new school
problems to deal with now, right?
So we've got misinformation,
we've got the social engineering and
what I call covert crowdsourcing.
So trying to get people into those echo
chambers on the different social media
platforms and trying to incite basically
either positive or negative emotions
around certain topics.
And then we also have this
misplaced faith in technology.
So I don't know how many of you spend
time in security operations center.
I've spent more hours than I care
to and security operations center,
I know Heather as as well.
And so these statistics
are pretty staggering given
the amount of money we have
spent on security technology.
So let's kind of just peel back a little
bit on these 56 56% of all alerts that
go into a security operation
center or investigated,
which means the 44% or not even looked
at it at all because there's just not
enough time and talent to
be able to run those down.
Then of those 56% alerts
that were actually looked at,
only 28% are deemed legitimate.
So the rest are just noise.
72% are just noise.
And then out of that smaller subset now,
so remember we went from 56% to 28%
so out of that 28% only 46% of those
actually get remediated.
Do we wonder why we have
the data breaches? We do.
Do we wonder why our infrastructure,
our cybersecurity resiliency
for companies is at risk?
Do we wonder why it's time to start naming
the human as any something else other
than they're the weakest link we have
to change how we focus on this case in
point.
The elections that better had been our
tsunami warning and I feel like a lot of
times the data breaches that we have,
we get excited about it.
Sort of like waking up really early in
the morning to go do something and then
somebody hits the snooze alarm
and it goes back to sleep.
We're all out of snooze alarms and
if Equifax it and do it for you.
The early warning signs that tsunami
bell going off with the elections
absolutely should because it's not
just in America, it's in other places.
So let's talk about kind of my point of
view on how I look at this and I welcome
any questions, comments on this
during the Q and a portion.
So I look at this and kind of three
components and the first one being is the
voter registration databases.
We know for a fact that those
were targeted by hackers.
We know that Chicago,
not Chicago,
the state of Illinois had to take their
voter registration database offline for
weeks during the summer leading
up to presidential election cycle.
They had had an incident and they felt
the best thing to do was to take it
offline to remediate the
incident before they came online.
Did that impact anybody's ability to vote?
I don't know if it did or not,
but I know during those weeks getting
a voter registration and if you were
somebody new to Illinois was not
hasty to do while that was down.
So you have the voter
registration databases,
you also have the polling
booths themselves. Now,
nobody has said that they have found
evidence of somebody went in and voted for
one person and on the back end a
different person was voted for.
Nobody has said that yet,
but ethical hackers at
black hat this year said,
if I have proximity and I have time,
I can absolutely do just that
and you may or may not know this,
but at the state level,
not,
not only does every state get a
chance to do this differently,
the counties and precincts within those
states may also do it differently and up
until this election cycle,
there was a race to go to
to the electronic only with
no paper trail for audit.
I don't know about you. I think
that sounds like a really bad idea.
I think we need a trust but verify
process here and really smart people are
working on this problem to make sure
from a voter registration database
perspective,
our data is more secure,
but this has to be solved
at the state level.
Lots of really smart people are working
on the actual polling booths themselves
and making sure that we don't allow
proximity and we don't allow time because
somebody with motive could do that.
And then the third piece is what I
talked about, which is our new domain.
We need to be worrying about insecurity,
which is the whole social media and
our inner connectedness on the internet
domain that needs to be
thought about differently.
And I'm just going to show you a couple
of quick headlines that have been in the
news recently. So and it,
and it's every company.
There is no one company at fault here,
but this better be our wake up call for
how we think about what happened during
the selection cycle.
Now don't get me wrong,
political espionage has been around since
they were two human beings on earth.
Okay?
So that's recorded history.
We know that propaganda has
been around for all of mankind.
But what happened,
this particular cycle,
both overseas and here in America,
was being able to produce
propaganda to push propaganda,
leverage these social media platforms
that have been designed to serve me and to
give me things that help me and assist me,
which means they know my likes and
preferences and because they do that,
the social media platforms were taken
advantage of and they were able to at a
speed,
never seen before in the history
of pushing political propaganda.
Not only push it out that to be able to
see in real time whether or not they had
an impact on you and me based on likes,
based on shares,
based on posts.
They never had that before.
They didn't know if it was working or not.
They to put boots on the ground and
they had to see whether or not they're
grassroots campaign was working.
So we have never seen what was done at
the speed and scale in which it was done,
not only to us but the
elections going on overseas.
And Google has recently
come forward and said,
you've done your own research and
you are taking this very seriously.
There's actually a proposed law,
and I always say be careful about new
proposed laws because they typically are
not going to stop bad things
from happening and in some
cases they're going to
create a situation that's so expensive
for you to comply with that it kind of
loses the spirit in which it was men.
But there's a law around sort of the,
you know,
the safety of ads in the political cycle
act that's being looked at on the hill
right now.
Let's bring it back to the humans though.
So if you remember wanna cry,
which was really bad,
especially for the UK, I was actually
in London, the day one a cry hit.
And what struck me was this was different
because typically ransomware is all
about how much bitcoin can I get out of
the victim and how much have it can I
wreak on them. In the
meantime, this was different.
People showed up for
surgery and more told,
I can't operate on you today because
we're under a ransomware attack.
People showed up sick and needing
prescriptions and they were told,
we can't write you a prescription today.
That to me is that,
that's where, this is not about how much
bitcoin did these guys get away with.
But at this point,
I think human safety trumps security.
And this is where we have to be
thinking about design a lot differently.
And so for my Monte Python fans,
um,
this is where I'm throwing the holy
hand grenade because we've been doing
security wrong and we need to
fix how we're focusing on this.
So what are some lessons learned? Um,
and I don't know if you know this,
this is actually a picture of the White
House flower shop, isn't it beautiful?
So after all that dark talk,
it's time for a zen moment.
And this is the beautiful White
House flower shops. So if you,
any Downton Abbey fans,
uh,
it's very much like that sort of the
ushers office underneath the White House
that keeps that sense of history
and protocol and class and elegance.
And I remember when I went into the
White House and I did my walkabouts.
So there's 13 components that make up
the executive office of the president.
And I went into the White House
flower shop in is just so beautiful.
And I noticed that as she was
making these flower arrangements,
they had bar codes on every single flower
and she would scan the flour with the
Barcode. She would cut it off and putting
the flower arrangement. And I thought,
well that's interesting.
Not really sure what that's all about.
So I go into the kitchen and they're
getting ready to make a big dinner.
And I noticed that the chicken breasts
and the pork chops and the paper towels,
they're all barcoded. And before
they get used, they're scanned,
barcodes are removed and they move on
with what they're doing. I'm like, okay,
I've read a lot of Brad Thor
novels and Vince Flynn novels.
I think I know what's going on here.
It's like to make sure there's no
anthrax poisoning and everything. Right.
So it's not like with love from
Russia or something like that.
So I go up to somebody and
the ushers office and I said,
what's going on here with the
barcodes? I think I know. And he says,
what do you think it is? And I said, it's,
you know, make sure it's not poisoned.
And he said, no, it definitely
helps with that, but that's
not why. And I said, okay,
well I know like if Queen Mum,
we're here,
you wouldn't want to run out of pork
chops. Right? That'd be embarrassing.
He can't run to the closest
grocery store and get pork chops.
So that's what it is. It's to make
sure from a supply chain standpoint.
And he said, well, it helps with that,
but that's not the reason why. And I said,
well, what is it? And he said, well,
it has to do with appropriations because
you see who's ever going to eat that
pork chop if it's a political dinner
versus an international head of state
visiting,
it's a different bucket of money and we
have to charge it to the right bucket of
money and hey,
this is your tax dollars at work for
those of you who are Americans here. Okay,
not making this up. And so they had to
scan it against the buckets of money.
So whoever was enjoying
the flower arrangement,
we had to make sure the right bucket
of money went to pay for those flowers.
Now I ask you, so we were doing the
right thing there, but I asked you,
when you think about the humans and the
humans involved in this and you think
about the data and all
data is not created equal.
So if you think about protecting data
and putting stricter standards on some,
an easier standards on other,
when you compare the number of chicken
breasts and baby's breath scan that day
versus the president's schedule,
which has everyone,
he's meeting with the secret service
agents down to the second where he's going
to turn a corner,
which one's more valuable
president's schedule.
The other thing I want you to be thinking
about too is that in my walkabouts,
I went and met with one of the other
components and one of these components
traveled with the president a lot and
most of what they did was not on the
classified systems,
but we had a rule that more than two
pieces of unclassified data basically
created a classified situation.
You know, just very sensitive.
Everything at the White House
is very sensitive information.
And so as a meeting with them, I said
to them, I was just asking everybody,
is there anything we do that's not
working for you? And so I asked them,
I know you're under a lot of tight
deadlines when you're on the road with the
president,
is there anything we ask you to do in
the name of security or in the name of
logistics that makes it hard for you
to do your job? And they said sure.
And I said, well what do you do because
you have these really tight deadlines.
And they said,
oh it's really simple.
We either take a picture of it or we
print screen it and we take it with us to
foreign countries.
And to which I kind of like had that
moment like that pit in your stomach
moment. And the old me from
financial services who was all about,
it's about training and it's just about
explaining to you wanting to come back
to the top. But the new me who said, I'm
not going to blame the human anymore,
I'm not going to say the human is the
weakest link. I'm going to say I am.
These are my designs. Okay, this
is our team doing the development.
I own this.
And so the new me listened
and the new me said,
why don't we get together and why
don't you show us what's going on here?
Because I realized I lost sight of
data because I had a bad design.
And so I want to push back on you a
little bit of always be thinking it's not
just feature and functionality from
the user experience. Never lose that.
Always have that at
the front of your mind.
But I need to push back and I need to
say the weakest link is actually in
development. We need to stop
relying on the human for this.
It's failing us every single time.
And then the last thing that I've
learned is you really need a kill switch.
And so Barbie, I dunno how many
of you know about talking Barbie,
but a Barbie when she first came out,
all her, most of these issues are fixed.
I'm going to talk to you about.
But when she first came out,
she computer viruses and she
also talked to any wifi network,
not just your home network but
any that said Barbie in it,
like wicked Barbie Evil Barbie,
like networks you shouldn't talk to.
And I was having one of those moments.
I was in the kitchen and I heard my
little girl may have say to her older
brothers, I think I'm going to ask Mama
for a talking Barbie for my birthday.
And so my middle one says, well how
does she work? Mave and she says, well,
according to the commercial,
I will talk to her,
she will listen to me and she'll actually
answer me back like in real time,
like no pause. She'll answer me
back. And my oldest one says,
I don't think mom was going to let you
have that because I'm assuming she's
probably talking to the cloud. You're
probably talking to someone in the cloud.
And My middle one says yen,
some Rando and so if you don't
have millennials in your life,
you know what Aramco is, right?
It's a random people rent.
So some random Joe who's going to help
the artificial intelligence interpret
everything you said to give you a
good answer back. And she said, yeah,
you're probably right. I'm going to
ask her an easy bake oven instead.
But my point in bringing up talking
Barbie is with when she had those computer
viruses,
when she was talking to Wifi network,
she shouldn't be talking to because you
don't know if they're trusted or not.
You could turn off her Internet
connection and still play with Barbie.
Just like I remember reading when the
nest had a software glitch and it wasn't
charging the battery. And so people on
the local news where like, oh my gosh,
it's getting cold.
What am I going to do?
My nest thermostats not
working and I'm thinking,
you do know you can walk to the
furnace and flip it on, right?
You do know that like the
thermostats just to help with thing.
And so that kill switch to
me is so vitally important
with what's going on today.
If you think about the incidents
like wanna cry or Equifax,
and the other piece you need to be asking
yourself though is when do I flip a
kill switch?
Right?
So when do I flip it with limited
functionality will be left.
What are the rules of engagement for this,
this kill switch and how do I
educate people to know it's there?
So the next time if somebody says,
look, there's an internet of things,
botnet rights, we were talking about
reaper last week or whatever it is,
that you have an easy seamless
way with your customers,
whether they're your business
customers or your consumer customers to
communicate with them,
everything's going to be okay.
Here's the kill switch in case it's not.
So if you admit all securities
defeatable if you think about sort of the
adversarial targeting like we did on
hunted, because the bad guys do this too.
If you have this aggressive offensive
and you're thinking ahead about how do I
have a kill switch,
how do I design for you?
So you're not having to worry
about this and plan ahead,
you're going to be so much better off.
So I want to leave you with some
new rules. And the first one is,
you probably have never heard
a security person say this,
but I want you to think
about your development where
you're putting a warm hug
around the user for
security, right? So we're,
it's almost like they don't
even have to think about it.
That's my timer to get
into our Q and a here.
New Domains to protect. So it's not just
the data, the devices, the hardware,
the software,
it's also social media and then the fact
that there is no perimeter to secure.
Uh, also for those of you
who are interested in, um,
kind of diversity in stem,
we do have a linkedin conversation called
help us sister up if you're interested
in it. It's just up there a few if
you want to reach out to us that way.
And there's my contact information
with that. Let's go to our Q and a
session. Create. So for
those of you in the audience,
do you think of your questions, but we're
going to take a dory question first.
And that question is,
could you tell us more about how you
became interested in this kind of work in
your journey into the field
or, um, and this is something Sarah
and I were talking about a little bit,
which I say I'm very blessed that
security actually came and found me. Uh,
when I first came out of graduate
school at University of Virginia,
my vision was I was going to
work on cutting edge technology,
innovative things that hadn't been dreamed
of yet and that's what I was going to
do. And uh, then I married somebody who
was in the navy and we got stationed in
Jacksonville,
Florida.
And I went to work in banking
and I actually got to be a,
I got hired into a group. They kind of
made a role around me and I was able to,
in addition to my day
duties as a programmer,
I'm in trouble support and helping people
with kind of their end user computing.
I was allowed to work on
innovative technologies.
And in doing that for anybody who's
worked with a financial services industry,
when you're on the leading edge of
technology are on the leading edge of
cybercrime and money
launderers and terrorists.
And that's really what got me kind
of passionate and fired up around
cybersecurity.
But at the same time creating it in
such a way that you still love doing
business with the bank,
but that we were fighting on your behalf
to keep the fraudsters of your account.
And it really just cemented for me.
Um,
when I got the opportunity to work
at the White House and the briefings,
you know,
the classified briefings,
you walk into that thinking you've kind
of seen it all in financial services and
you walk into these briefings and
realized I was looking into a keyhole in a
tiny room and I had no real idea about
the capabilities of the adversary.
And so that's when I made my commitment
that however many years I had left on
this earth to work,
that I would use it to fiercely defends
people and companies and the government
and our allies from bad people.
Yeah.
Hey,
um,
and you get a book for asking the first
you can ask and I already get that.
This is an exciting thank you.
So the question actually relates
directly to the title of your book. Um,
I'm on the federated
identity team here at Google.
So I think a lot about people's identities
on the Internet and something your
demo tape made me think about was that
a lot of the ways that when people
strengthened their internet identity,
like when we think of the
early days of the Internet,
people had very anonymous identities.
Um, and now more and more,
especially with Google products,
we are giving you a stronger and
stronger presence online. Um,
and on the product side we think of a
lot of ways that that can be helpful for
you. And then this video reminded
me that two people, uh, ed,
particularly law enforcement,
there are a lot of ways that having a
stronger identity is really great for
being tracked or censored or any of
these other really bad security related
issues.
So I was wondering if you had any ideas
for addressing that or any examples that
you've seen in your career where
having a stronger internet identity can
actually make you safer
from something malicious?
Maybe not a valid police
investigation, but a, uh,
not so valid police investigation.
Yeah. We, I think, uh,
well for example, we have,
we have had situations with
mistaken identity where
because of that kind of lack
of clarity around identity,
you've had people wrongly accused and
handling nuclear, their name, you know,
police knocking at their door and
they're like on, it really wasn't me.
You've got the wrong person.
And so I do think you're creating,
what I would say is,
and I think there's a lot in the product
development that Google's doing right
on this, which is you're informing
people on what to opt in and opt out on,
on kind of the identity management.
And I think it can be a really good thing.
At the same time,
it does create a little bit of,
um,
I'm in a conundrum about it myself
because when I think about especially the
generation coming up,
they're questioning and learning and
they're treating it all as a conversation
online and there's a
generation ahead of them,
maybe multiple generations ahead
of them that once it's written,
it's now almost like that's a fact about
you versus a conversation around the
dinner table.
And so I worry for people who want to
leverage the Internet to reach out to
other people who don't think like them,
to challenge their own intellectual
thought process on different topics that
it's going to be held against them. And,
and that's unfortunate. And so that,
I think,
to me that's the conundrum I'm in,
which is I would like to see stronger
identity online. I'd like to see,
um,
you know,
better kind of identity access management
for more security and privacy based on
opting in and opting out.
But at the same time I'm hesitant
because I'm worried that,
and kind of having that
identity that follows you,
you don't get to choose what
people see and don't see. And,
and that's a conundrum for me and I,
I don't actually have a good answer for
you on that except for keep pushing,
keep pushing and your product design
and the developers around what are the
longterm impacts on people, um, for the,
for things potentially following their
identity. Can you get a new identity?
Can you decide like,
I've grown up now and that's not me.
And can you leave that behind?
And for many of us who are digital
immigrants and not digital natives. Yeah,
I'd like to think I'm a digital native,
but technically based on birth year,
I'm not a, but you know, I
started programming in school.
So for me I think that way. But when
you think about true digital natives,
there's no on and off the web.
And so for them that, that's what I
worry about. Great question. Awesome.
Thank you.
Great. And our next question
is what do you think the,
or what do you see as the biggest
challenge right now with the Internet of
things?
Uh,
um,
you know what's interesting
on the Internet of things
I've noticed there tends
to be in the security industry,
they're so focused on we need to make
sure that that device itself that's going
to be secure.
And that's the problem.
And I am actually pushing back on
that and saying, if you think about,
I had a picture in the presentation,
the Tacoma Narrows Bridge for the
1940s the Tacoma narrows bridge,
if you look it up, it was built out
of concrete and steel independently,
very strong materials.
We didn't think about the
enterprise architecture
enough and it literally looked
like a piece of taffy pulling. Thankfully
nobody lost their lives that day,
but the bridge collapsed under I
think 40 mile an hour wind shears.
And so the Internet of things,
to me,
I think that the biggest concern for me
is we're so focused on how do I get that
component secure.
We're not actually thinking about how
has that component part of a bigger
enterprise architecture and how do we
know when that component is behaving badly
either because of bad guy took it over
or there's something wrong with it.
And how do we know when that technology
is obsolete and because it's so embedded
in what we're doing, we don't even know
it's there. So kind of another story.
It's not internet of things,
but there a house where the phone started
dialing a random number several times
a day for six weeks and nobody could
figure out why the phone was doing that.
And what they realized was,
is the previous owners had announced,
not used oil tank and technology
had been fitted on the oil tank,
that when it went under a
certain level of being full,
it would automatically
dial the oil company,
which is now no longer in business
owners changed hands on the house.
So when the new owners come in,
they reconnect the line for the house
and all of a sudden the oil tank is now
calling the now defunct and now that
number belongs to somebody else.
And it took them six weeks to figure it
out. And everybody can have a big laugh.
But at the time people were just like,
I don't understand.
Like is there a ghost in this house?
Like what is going on?
And I worry about that for the Internet
of things is that we've had them so
embedded that as that
technology becomes obsolete,
are we going to remember it's
there and what happens when it,
they think actually a lightening strike
is what turned everything back on.
So it's almost like it
rebooted the program.
And so what happens when
we forget they're there?
Yes,
I thank you for your talk. I work in
user experience for Security and privacy,
so I appreciate it. A
lot of what you said. Um,
what are the top pieces of advice you
would give a consumer today to protect
themselves online?
Or a couple of things.
I mean,
one is never use free Wifi
and it's one of those things,
you know. So I took, uh, our intern
Steven to a coffee shop in Charlotte,
which is a huge banking town. And I told
him, take your pineapple, take your Mac.
I'm going to take my pineapple on my Mac
and I'm going to hack you and see how
you do and then you're going to
hack me back and see how you do.
And because we have this whole moral
ethics code at four Dulles where we say,
just because you can doesn't mean
you should. He said to me, ma'am,
how are we going to make sure we don't
accidentally hack other people in the
coffee shop? I said, it's very simple.
What we're gonna do is we're
going to name our wifi hotspots,
something nobody would ever connect to.
So we're not going to name
at the coffee shop name,
we're going to name it
something ridiculous. So I
named the first iteration,
I named it and I named it fake Wifi and
five people connected within minutes.
And so people's traffic are coming by
and Steven's getting upset and I said
that's okay. Well I'm plugging it,
Steve, I'm going to let you name it.
So he says no one will ever connect to
this network and it calls it data stealer
and 10 people connected.
And so my point in bringing this up
is it's like you have people who,
I know data plans are really expensive
and so they're trying to use free wifi
everywhere they go and they don't really
realize that they need to be using a
virtual private network in addition
to using that free Wifi to help.
Not that doesn't block 100% of all
bad things, but it sure helps a ton.
So that would be the first thing is get
a really good VPN that you're really
comfortable with.
Use that everywhere you go,
especially when you go
overseas on vacation.
Cause that's a really popular
time for people to get hit. Uh,
don't use free Wifi.
But if you have to have that Vpn,
I also say segment your life.
So just like we talked about network
segmentation and data segmentation.
Really briefly segment your life.
Have one email address that you use with
your bank that you don't use anywhere
else.
Have one with your health care because
health insurance fraud is really high
right now. Have one that you use
for sensitive confidential emails.
I hate email but sometimes the
person on the other end of the line,
the only thing they want to do is
send me this confidential email.
And so I personally for that use
a whole different email platform,
a two factor authentication that
is annoying to most consumers.
Just understand that they don't like it,
they don't want to do it.
But if you're somebody who's um,
on line and you've got that
particular email tied to other things,
you need two factor authentication. Uh,
and then kind of the last thing would be,
you know,
as it relates to any of the major issues
that are going on in the world and in
this country,
do your homework.
Don't allow things that are posted on
your friend's walls and on your wall.
Don't allow that to create
extreme emotions for you.
Whether those are highs or lows,
do your homework,
pick out your own news organizations
that are on both sides of different
arguments and don't react to what you're
seeing right now and make sure you,
you do your own homework and things so
that you can really think and make up
your own mind for yourself.
So those would be some of the bigger
things that I would advise. Yup.
Great question.
Great. Our next question is, um,
you mentioned being cautious
of new laws in this space.
What steps should lawmakers and
or the government in general,
it'd be taking to keep us safe online,
especially when we consider one a cry
and the impact that it had on the health
sector?
Yeah, it's a very fair question and
uh, you know, it's interesting. I,
if anything actually
gets passed on the hill.
So that's kind of the first big one,
which is they're not getting along.
I don't know if you've noticed and not,
not a lot has been passed in recent years,
but if anything were to pass,
given what's happened
in the past with OPM,
with some of the credit card breaches.
But when you look at Experian,
that's permanent data.
So the last breaches were credit cards.
You get a new credit card basically after
a year you should be fine experience.
You're never getting a new mothers
may name social security number,
date of birth,
they can wait 10 years.
And that data's still golden until America
as a government figures out what our
new identification Schema is going to
be for the different parts of your life,
whether it's the IRS or a security
or whatever it is. And so I'll,
I would be a big fan of seeing some
type of a consumer bill of rights around
data and data privacy.
But I am hesitant to push for something
like that because I worry that by the
time it's inaccurate, it's out of
date. And then two, I worry that,
well meaning well-intended,
but not technical people will be dictating
for companies how to technically take
care of that. But, uh, but if you
were to ask the hill for anything,
I would ask the hill, uh, for
things that are incentive based.
So for example,
I would love to see companies that invest
in security and privacy get an r and d
tax credit for that.
How about the fact that you're being a
good citizen and you're investing money
and thinking about this
problem differently.
Why not give you a tax
break for doing that?
So why don't we think instead about
sort of onerous regulatory burdens,
why don't we think of incentives and
saying for companies who do right by this,
let's give them a break for,
you know,
designing differently and designing
for the human instead of designing and
saying the humans the weakest link.
And, um, we'll take one more
question again. Um, this is,
I think the most fun one.
Oh,
what was the most difficult fugitive
strategy to figure out on hunted or
otherwise? What were some of the most
creative and effective disappearances?
Wow, that's a good way. I
mean, candidly, I'll give,
try and Shelly some
real props. Uh, so what,
what you need to know for those of you,
if you haven't watched the show yet,
you can binge watch it on. And again, my
mom says it's a must march show, but uh,
you can binge watch it on CBS on demand
and I think it's on Hulu and Amazon.
You can download the series. And one of
the things about Troy and Shelly, um, it,
well for you to know
about all the fugitives,
I had no idea what they went through
other than the capture and they didn't let
me see it until the show aired.
So I learned with everybody at home where
people really were and the near misses
that we had. And so Troy and Shelly, they
were actually in the swamp for 14 days,
straight canoeing past alligators.
I don't know if you've spent
any time in the Florida swamp.
It is not a pretty place to be.
And so I give them total
props for doing that. And uh,
it was really their friends commenting
on there, they're wanted page, uh,
that really kind of helped us figure
out who would be in the local area that
might be helping them.
Uh,
another kind of creative thing that David
and Emily did was David had actually,
uh,
when in that first hour before they're
given a full hour ahead of us knowing who
they are to do anything they
want to do to get ready,
but they have to show their getting
ready and that they weren't a prepper in
advance.
And one of the things he did was he
called different people to have them be
lifelines in line over
the course of the 20 days.
And he set up,
basically they were three degrees of
separation away from him and they did all
the coordination for him.
And so even though we're trying to surveil
him and his family and Emily and her
family really, he had gone way
out of his circle of trust.
And so that made it harder
for us to figure out who,
cause you can only surveil so many
people in 28 days and convinced the court
too. You have to have just cars
to put people under surveillance.
You have to have a really well
written warrant for that. I was,
that was another really good strategy.
And then you know, it was interesting,
the boys will and miles would,
they basically did was they just lived
off of the kindness of strangers,
which really was going to work
for them until I'm one of the,
one of the people who was
helping them out. Um, the,
the friend wanted to go to a movie and
they didn't want to leave the boys alone
in the vacation rental.
And so she actually called our tip line
and turn them in because she was tired
of them hanging out.
So it's like when you do on the kindness
of strangers and they had no digital
footprint. The only, only thing I
thought was when I read their profile,
I said they're going to go to the beach
and cause the hundred thousand square
miles was the southeast for season one.
So I said,
they're going to go to the beach
because they can blend in. They kind of,
you know, they're young men, they're
going to blend in at the beach.
They like to have a good time.
That's a great place to hide. And so,
but there's myrtle beach and there's
Florida beaches and there's all kinds of
beaches. And a, that's
really was their undoing,
was living off the kindness of strangers
and one of them got tired of them and
turn them in.
Excellent.
Well this has been really fascinating and
we do appreciate you joining us today.
I'm so a big round of applause
for chase everybody. Thank you.